so you sing opera right you were in an
opera right
did you actually end up performing
sometimes i put skis on and i go down a
mountain but that doesn't make me as
fear
you know what i mean so that's me in a
snowboard
so so i can carry a tune you know i had
a i had a weird stammer when i was a kid
and i had a music teacher who helped me
with that
and through music i sort of discovered
some things about myself that i
that i didn't know um and so when i when
i decided to try and get in the
entertainment business
the opera represented a loophole
like if you can get into the opera you
have your agma card your american guild
of musical artists and that lets you buy
your screen actors guild card
what i needed was my screen actors guild
card but i couldn't get hired
to work in television because i wasn't
part of the union and i couldn't get in
the union because i hadn't worked in
television
i it's such a weird thing i know it's
stupid but
the way in for me was to learn the
shortest aria i could find
uh and crash and audition for the
baltimore opera
and just sing it as loud as i could and
hope that they needed
young guys with low voices and um
somehow they let me in and i figured i
would stay for a performance or two
you know maybe half a season but the
music was better than i thought
and um the girls were like everywhere
and i was like everywhere y'all are
outnumbered so
i mean no that's awesome i love first of
all because i've sang
arya's before and i grew up singing
operatic stuff all the time so
i love that you are just like sure i'll
find an aria
walk into an audition and nail it that
is
bold i went to rosedale public library
and i said to the librarian i said look
i'm going to try and force
my way into the opera although that was
before forrest gump i said foreign
give me something simple that i can
memorize so it was uh la boheme
it was the coat aria and i walked around
baltimore
in like 1984 with with a walkman on my
head
listening to samuel raymie sing it over
and over i didn't know what the words
meant
i just memorized the sounds and the
melody yeah and that's all i knew when i
when i went in gosh that's i mean that's
insane
that's a gift just you know like not
everyone did the same i mean what was
american idol you know
no but i'm just saying i but i was
trained far before that like
not in pop singing but i just mean and
like singing like i was used to audition
i was used to
like from childhood so like that was
that was a different thing that was
not that was way more bold what you did
um but mike
i wanna i don't wanna put you on this
spot but i'm gonna like you could say no
but i kind of wanna hear you seeing
opera because your voice is such
beautiful tone
can you sing something lj you want me to
sing something
go ahead brother yes all right i'm gonna
hit you with a little italian this is
the audition
this is the beginning of the audition
piece i had no idea what the words meant
i learned them later but this is what
got me into the baltimore opera
okay thank
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh your tone is magical
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going